hi everyone thanks for having me very
excited to tell you a little bit about
my work on aligning human and robot
representations
and this is pretty much me in a nutshell
I develop robot algorithms I learned
from people from various sorts of data
from them and I do that because I really
believe that if we want robust and not
just exist in a vacuum they have to be
capable to adapt to the people that
they're interacting with
and as a running example let's take this
Jayco robot arm that's trying to carry
the smug over to my lab mate
and maybe some of your ex-lab mate so
here Jayco can generate trajectories eye
that optimize some sort of pre-specified
reward function are and typically these
reward functions are parameterized by by
a Theta encoding a trade-off between
different features of the task things
like the mug orientation the distance to
the table or efficiency
and here Jayco starts off initially only
caring about being efficient so it just
follows the shortest path from start to
goal but then I eventually noticed that
Jacob was actually carrying the cup a
little bit too high from the table so
what I can do is I can push on it to
correct it and the robot can use my
correction to adapt to how to up adapt
this data and adapt to how I wanted the
task to be done and thus finished
carrying the mug closer to the table to
my lab mate and this is kind of one
example of robots adapting to how people
want their task to be done and in fact
I'm on this AI floor at Berkeley full of
brilliant people who similarly think
about getting robots that do hard tasks
for humans so in this example they
wanted to create a robot Butler that can
serve one to customers and so they came
up with this
so from an AI perspective this is an
amazing feat of Robotics you get this
robot that can carry this glass of wine
incredibly fast without spilling without
breaking the glass or anything
now from a human user perspective I
don't know by you but if this is how the
robot acted around me I would be pretty
terrified
so while this robot achieves something
that is very technically impressive it
kind of fails to consider that a real
human customer would be too scared of
their perception of the robot spilling
or breaking the glass to have a good
time
and so we're kind of seeing this amazing
progress and getting robots to do really
hard stuff and isolation but not so much
in doing those hard tasks around people
necessarily and we see the consequences
of this all the time in the news and
this Uber crash in Arizona in 2018 you
have this autonomous car that fatally
hit a jaywalking pedestrian for the
simple reason that it didn't understand
the concept of a jaywalking pedestrian
that was only programmed to know about
pedestrians across walks and then on the
flip side on the right hand side you
have this kind of the flip side scenario
where this time the human didn't know
about a new feature that was programmed
into this flight control system it
didn't understand what it was doing so
they entered this tug of war ultimately
those diving into the ocean
and so this kind of tells us that human
robot interaction is still very hard
and to understand the reason underlying
all of these failures I want to share
with you an example of failed human
human interaction okay okay we'll have
more quarters
or are they the same the same okay now
watch
now does this row have more quarters
does this room have more quarters or are
they the same that one has more quarters
that one has more quarters why does it
have work orders because it's stretched
out
okay this is my impersonation of this
child since we don't have sound
um so here this child is clearly missing
something right he's missing this
concept the conservation of certain
properties very normal for a child this
age this doesn't develop until a little
bit later but without understanding this
concept the child is making the wrong
inferences to the researchers questions
and not only that he's also able to
explain his wrong inferences with these
other Concepts that he does know about
that are actually quite unrelated
and so now let's take this and translate
it into our Jayco example and let's say
that this time I actually want my robot
to not carry the cup above my personal
laptop but the robot has no notion of
distance from laptops and without it it
can't learn one well from my push and
even worse it latches onto other
Concepts that it knows about like
distance the table similarly to how that
child was latching onto other Concepts
so that's why in my view our biggest
obstacle to successful human robot
interaction well should have let this
play is the fact that the
representations that humans and robots
have are more often than not misaligned
and that's why I spent a lot of time in
my PhD working on what I call the
representation alignment problem or in
other words how can we get robots to
align the representations with those of
the humans that they're interacting with
and learning from
and so far we've seen kind of one more
traditional approach to this the one
where you have a system designer that
just hand specifies these
representations fee and code and then
the robot can learn how to do the task
on top of this by learning a reward
function from test specific input ah
like the corrections that we just saw or
many other types of feedback and then it
can optimize that the produced
trajectories in the world
the only problem with this is that you
need to specify ahead of time all of
these features in the representation and
it's fairly unrealistic to assume that a
system designer can sit and think about
what every single human in any task in
any environment could possibly care
about ahead of time
so then you might say Andrea there's a
very simple solution to this deep
learning just learn the features as well
after all that is what the Deep learning
revolution has been promising us to do
and I tried that and let's see what
happens
so if the person cares about keeping the
cup close to this table that we just saw
and away from the laptop we might think
of the reward function spatially as
looking like something like this where
it's really low when you look right
above the laptop and a high above from
the table and it gets better the closer
to the table and farther from the laptop
you look
so when the robot is missing some
feature like the distance to the laptop
deep learning just tells us that we can
model what's missing with a big big deep
Network you can collect a few
demonstrations of how to do the task
from the human and then you can try to
learn both what's missing and the reward
function kind of all at once from those
demonstrations
and this is kind of what happens when
you do this we see that we vaguely
learned that being around the laptop is
bad but we don't really learned these
more fine-grained causal details of the
reward function
now why is that
well the demonstrations that we're
getting they're meant to teach the robot
how to do the task they aren't meant to
teach the robot about features per se
and so with the structure you're just
kind of hoping to pick up on What's
Missing implicitly from these
demonstrations
but by trying to kind of do everything
at once like both of these things at
once deep learning ends up generalizing
pretty poorly
and the implication is that if I now
take this reward function and I optimize
it I produce this pretty sub-optimal
behavior in contrast to how I would have
done the task
so we have one Paradigm that learns good
rewards but requires handcrafted
representations the other skips all that
feature specification but you do a
pretty poor job generalizing
so my question has been can we somehow
bridge the gap here can we still have
some learning involved but recover
something that's more structured and
more salient
and rather than assuming a
representation or just hoping that it
will just pick it up along the way a
core idea and my work has been that
robots should directly engage with
humans in an interactive process for
arriving at shared representations
and in my thesis this has led to a
divide and conquer approach to robot
learning where I'm kind of asking can we
first Focus explicitly on learning the
representation from Human input before
using that representation for learning
the downstream task
so what's really nice about this is that
we're not just stuck with demonstrations
we can actually Design This human input
ahv that's targeted at explicitly
teaching about the representation itself
and can do can do that effectively
and so that's what I'm going to talk
about throughout my PhD I've studied how
to formalize this idea of representation
alignment in a lot of directions but
obviously I don't have time to talk
about everything so I'm going to only
show you a quick taste of just these
three today because all of these three
kind of make a play a critical role in
making this Vision work
and I'll mostly focus on this first one
how do we learn representations from
humans and we're going to see the other
two only kind of
um flashed real quick
come back to this example where we had
the Deep inverse reinforcement learning
or IRL method that model the missing
feature as a neural network and
collected some some demonstrations to
learn both what's missing and the reward
kind of both at once
and what if instead of trying to do both
of these things at once we apply this
divide and conquer philosophy and we
first focus on learning the missing
feature from some mystery human input
that I'll tell you about in just a
second and only then focused on learning
the reward on top from reward specific
inputs like the demonstrations or the
corrections from earlier and so that's
what we're going to do
so we can still model the missing
features in neural network but what is
this this magical mystical
representation specific type of feedback
that can help us learn features
well the most naive approach to this
would be to just ask the person directly
for labels representing the feature
value at different states in the state
space and then you can just use these
labels directly for supervision and
train your neural network function
directly
there's a couple problems with this
first the cover the space you would need
the robot we need a ton of labels which
is not super human data efficient
and it's too burdensome
but even worse people are not exactly
great at giving real valued labels
something like 0.32 is not easy for us
to express
turns out that we can actually
alleviate the second Problem by instead
asking the person for relative labels
that kind of compare the feature values
in pairs of States across the state
space and then you can train your neural
network with what is called the Bradley
Terry model for pairwise comparisons
but even so you still need a ton of
comparisons
so how do we solve this problem
well my take on this was that humans are
a lot more competent than just providing
zero one labels so long as we give them
the right way to give us data
and so what I wanted here was to come up
with some sort of feature input that is
informative but doesn't place too much
sample complexity burden on the human
so our idea was that we can pack a lot
more information if we instead ask the
person for a sequence of states with the
property of the feature values along
that sequence are monotonically
decreasing and we call a sequence of
this property of feature trades
and now the robot can automatically
extract comparisons by exploiting this
monotonicity and I'll get into this in
just a second but first I want to show
you in practice what this feature Trace
looks like so in practice if I want to
teach the robot about something like
this does the laptop I start somewhere
where the feature value is highly
expressed so right above the laptop and
I move the robot monotonically towards
an area where it's not highly expressed
so away from the laptop and the robot
can collect a few of these traces and
can learn a feature function that's
defined by them
so now how does it do that I want to
walk us through how the robot can
actually take advantage of this
structure that's really nicely packed
into these feature traces and how it can
transform those traces into these State
comparisons that we can use that we can
use to train the network with this
Bradley Terry model up top
so first we know that feature traces
satisfy this monotonicity property so
that means that the feature values
decrease along the states of the trace
and what this means is that I can take
any ordered combination of two states
along the trace and I can label it one
meaning that I know that the first one
is going to have a higher feature value
than the second one
and what's really special about this is
that from just one Trace I am kind of
getting for free a quadratic number of
State comparisons a number of State
comparisons that's quadratic in the
length of the trace and we get that for
every single trade so that's a ton of
data
the second thing that I know is that I
can also relate the feature values
across traces because I know that all
traces approximately start high and and
low that means that for any two traces
the starts should be approximately
equally High feature value-wise and the
same for the ends where they should be
approximately equally low
then that gives us equivalence two
points with a label of 0.5 the symbolize
equal preference
and so now we can take these two sets of
tuples and incorporate them into a
cross-entropy loss that is based off of
this rally Terry model and just train
this simple multi-layer perceptron for
this
so now I want to showcase some actual
examples of features that we managed to
train using this method using feature
traces with from both expert users aka
me on a physical robot as well as
non-expert users in an kind of online
user study and simulation this would
this happened the simulation online
because this project happened in summer
of 2020 so we couldn't exactly invite
people into our lab
and for all evaluations what we can do
is we can sample a test set of states
and the robot's reachable set then we
can color them with the value of the
feature that we're trying to visualize
so here I'm coloring the distance to
laptop feature and we see that it's
yellow when the end effector is right
above the laptop and it goes towards
blue when you go away
and something else that's nice that I
can do is I can take this 3D ball and
project it onto a representative plane
like so
okay so when we look at the ground truth
laptop feature we see this projected
feature density ball that kind of
decreases the farther away you look from
the laptop Center
and when we collect traces from the
expert our method learns a structurally
very similar feature and in fact this
holds across six different euclidean
features that we looked at I'm not going
to get into detail of what these are but
what I do want to point out is that each
of these features was trained with
somewhere around 10 to 15 feature traces
not the Thousand demonstrations that
end-to-end methods might have required
and I want to also show some qualitative
results from our user study because
ultimately we wanted to know does this
work with real people who are not
experts can real people actually program
their robots in their home to do this
and so what we're seeing is for distance
to laptop real users some non-expert
users gave these traces that also
similarly start at the center and move
away from the laptop in all directions
and you can recover this projected ball
that looks very similar to what we saw
on the previous slide
for distance the table they cover the
space vertically from up to down
and my personal favorite is this
proxemics feature which is this idea
that people really dislike having things
in front of their face more so than to
their sides and so my favorite thing is
that people figured out on their own
that the way to teach this is to give
these traces that are longer in front of
them and then shorter and shorter to
their sides and you so you recover this
kind of half Ellipsis when you project
it that's kind of consistent with my
description of the proximics feature
this is this idea of learning features
efficiently from Human supervision we
managed to actually generalize this the
more complex settings not just euclidean
settings so we generalize that the
perceptual features which the robot can
learn and use directly from camera input
and we also looked at emotion features
which the robot can use to produce
expressive motion
all right so now that we've seen how we
can learn features one at a time I want
to ask the question how does the robot
even know when its representation is
misaligned with the humans in the first
place and thus needs to learn features
so that's what we're going to quickly go
over in the second part
and going back to this scenario recall
that without knowing about this feature
the robot kind of blindly learned to
stay close to the table which is not
what I wanted it to do
so instead is there any way in which the
robot can kind of autonomously figure
out that it is missing something that it
doesn't that my push refers to something
that it just doesn't know about so
that's what we're going to ask here
and since people when they act they
don't just do so randomly we used what
we call what is called the boltzmann
noisily rational model Which models
people as selecting inputs in proportion
to their exponentiated reward
and what's really nice about this model
is this coefficient beta over here which
models how optimal or rational the
person is and typically in robotics this
beta is fixed to be something reasonably
High essentially assuming that people
will be reasonably rational
but says here we're trying to explicitly
detect misalignment we know that from
the robot's perspective that's not
necessarily going to be the case
and so we didn't do that here and
instead we estimated this beta we
reinterpret it as a confidence in how
much it can the robot can explain the
human's input and we estimated both beta
and Theta
so what this means is that when the
human and robot representations are
aligned the robot can estimate the high
confidence on the correct intent Theta
that explains the human's input and thus
it can learn assuredly from what the
human is doing but when they are
misaligned the robot estimates a low
confidence across its representation and
does not learn from inputs that it does
not understand
so going back to this example this time
when I push on the robot it infers a low
confidence and as you can see in Orange
it doesn't incorrectly learn to stay
close to the table
importantly this is not something that
we hand tune the robot kind of is
automatically monitoring its confidence
and it can learn and proportion to that
confidence as it did here or you could
just completely stop execution entirely
in safety critical situations
I'm going to skip some user study videos
that I have in the interest of time but
I quickly wanted to just point out that
this framework generalizes Beyond
Corrections we did this for learning
from demonstrations we did this for tele
operation so this is something that
generalizes much much broadly
and lastly to then properly learn from
and interpret people's input you also
need a model for how people make choices
I'm not going to dive deep into this but
we did find that this boltzmann model
that I just introduced it's actually
quite unintuitive and we presented this
more natural model called less now where
we said that we should use the human
aligned representation to kind of
account for any similarity that the
potential trajectories have to one
another
um long story short we run a user study
and we confirmed that our model does
indeed better capture how people make
decisions and this has implications
Beyond cognitive Beyond robotics the
cognitive science and econometrics and
anywhere you need a human model
so all in all when you put everything
together and you go back and try to do
reward learning what you see is that
what our divide and conquer approach we
recover much more generalizable rewards
when compared to end to end which was
completely failing
um I don't know if I can can I have like
two minutes to talk about high level
stuff or should I wrap it up one minute
okay all right uh well the robot here
now that's the line I can do the task
how I wanted it
um but what I wanted to talk about
really quickly is that we we sort of put
forward this vision of getting uh robots
to engage with humans in this
interactive process for arriving at
shared representations but in these 20
minutes we really just talked about
um this very standard approach where the
human is the teacher feeding the robot
data about their representation in
reality what I've really love to have in
seamless human robot interaction and
collaboration would be more than just
passive data absorption but more like
this bi-directional process where the
robot is actually an active participant
in the interaction and so this is kind
of a vision for like where
representation alignment should go in
the future it should be this more active
bi-directional process
um
okay I'm not going to go too in depth
into this but you can see this in
personal robotics where robots work
alongside humans you need
representational alignment to enable the
robot to easily learn new things new
tasks from humans as the context changes
but you also need to enable the robot to
communicate back its failures to the
human so that it's more transparent in
the case of failure
uh and semi-autonomous driving we would
really love for the robot to behave
according to user expectations and if it
doesn't like in that aircraft example
then it should detect that and
relinquish control to the pilot and this
isn't specific to just experienced
Pilots we want autonomy that can adapt
to users of all different levels of
expertises and preferences
I also Envision AVS also interacting
with the passengers themselves I'm sure
maybe some of you know there's waymo
cars going on in San Francisco I got the
try one and my HRI brain kept looking at
this interface and thinking that there's
so much potential for personalization
and this car could really learn a lot
about me
and lastly there's a lot of potential
for shared autonomy which is meant to
assist in augment Human Performance
where the robot should really adapt to
different changing human capabilities as
the person learns more and more about
how to use it it's their their robot
um okay all of these exciting Avenues
are possible because we're explicitly
sitting down and thinking about aligning
representations rather than just hoping
it's going to naturally emerge
I'd like to thank my collaborators and
happy to take any questions
[Applause]
thank you it was amazing a great talk I
had a question about the learning the
representations when you had this the
features when you had the laptop
experiment uh you are using learning
those features one by one right
sorry the
um for the laptop for example you're in
the table and you're doing these like
collecting these data for only one
feature at a time feature at a time
um how easy is to combine those features
because you are kind of like are you
assuming that they are starting from the
same value and would that be true all
the time ah are you saying how can you
combine them into a reward function
because what if they live on different
like intense like values yeah so what if
you want to really avoid the laptop we
kind of normalize them to be between
zero and one that's how we normalize the
training to be between zero and one
where one is the kind of highest
intensity that just makes the reward
learning easier
um but I mean it's not
it's not
mandatory you don't have to do that okay
all right thank you
it definitely has to be positive though
all right and well in that case I thank
you and
thanks thank you
[Applause]